okay mark you've been doing comedy for
how many 15ish 15ish but who's counting
yeah epstein's favorite number
do you remember your first bit that
worked yes and i'm not proud of it but
uh the joke was very woody allen-esque
i'm bad in bed i'm so bad in bed when my
me and my first girlfriend decided to
lose our virginity to each other i bled
hey it still works was that the one that
amy saw no no that was a different one i
bombed i was bombing at this club in new
york and i was a new open mic horrible
comic and uh she happened to walk
through the club as i did one joke in
that set that worked and she was like oh
that's funny and i saw her in the green
room she was like that joke was killer i
was like oh really i'm covered in sweat
you know i'm like oh yeah thank you
yeah
this is amy schumer you're talking about
yeah years ago yeah
uh it was it's a long joke but it's
basically uh
people say the term i don't [ __ ] around
too loosely like my friend went to the
grocery store and bought wheat fins and
i was like oh wheat then son he goes
yeah i don't [ __ ] around
you want crackers you know blah blah
blah and it killed yeah and everything
else bombed but she saw that joke thank
god this the timing was perfect and then
she goes hey we should do some dates on
the road i was like oh my god okay and
this is before she was amy you know she
was like a
you know club comic with half-filled
rooms so you knew who she was at the
time i knew who she was because i knew i
knew all the new york comics but uh it
was a dream come true and then i watched
her go from clubs to theaters to the
garden to movies to
literally hosting the oscars almost
affected your material knowing her
audience as you like
i was so green i was just trying to get
laughs i was just doing anything but uh
she she showed me a lot about the
business and taught me a lot about
you know how to make it and all that
stuff she's a she's a real pro in that
way well did you have any idea she'd
become who she is today even at that
time no i mean i could see that she oh
she got the roast she got the charlie
sheen rose oh she got a tv show inside
amy schumer and i was watching her blow
up but uh it was so fast that i was just
in a whirlwind like one night we're on a
private jet i'm like how the hell this
happened you know
so i just got to see it in real time she
kept you and she kept me is she the best
current active
female comedian i know you don't want to
go male female
but i do think that guys typically are
funnier than girls i said it
but i think probably marjorie taylor
green number one i mean
jewish space laser that is comedy gold
that's true
[Music]
you